>>> TONIGHT THE WHITE HOUSE IS
ON THE DEFENSIVE AND SCRAMBLING
TO DEAL WITH THE NATIONWIDE
SHORTAGE OF BABY FORMULA AS
INCREASINGLY DESPERATE PARENTS
PLEAD FOR ANSWERS.
LET'S GO TO THE WHITE HOUSE
CORRESPONDENT JEREMY DIAMOND.
SO WHAT'S THE WHITE HOUSE DOING
TO TRY TO FIX THIS SHORTAGE IN
BABY FORMULA THAT LEFT PARENTS
SCRAMBLING?
>> Reporter: PRESIDENT BIDEN
TODAY OUTLINING A NUMBER OF
STEPS THAT THE ADMINISTRATION IS
TAKING TO TRY TO ADDRESS THE
SHORTAGE INCLUDING STANDING UP
HHS.GOV/FORMULA WITH INFORMATION
TO GET FORMULA, THE HOTLINES FOR
MANUFACTURERS AND OTHER
MEDICALLY RELEVANT INFORMATION
AND WORKING WITH STATE AGENCIES
AND THE MANUFACTURERS TO ENSURE
FAMILIES ON WIC CAN PURCHASE ANY
BRAND THEY WANT NOT JUST SIMILAC
WHICH IS THE SOURCE OF THE
VOLUNTARY RECALL AND CONSIDERING
USING THE DEFENSIVE PRODUCTION
ACT.
THAT WOULD BE LONGER TERM BUT
NEXT WEEK THE FDA IS ANNOUNCING
STEPS TO STREAMLINE TO IMPORT
FORMULA FROM ABROAD AND A STEP
THAT THE COMMISSIONERS SAYS WILL
IMPROVE THE SUPPLY IN THE U.S.
IN A MATTER OF WEEKS.
PRESIDENT BIDEN IS FACING
CRITICISM FROM REPUBLICANS
SAYING THAT HE SHOULD HAVE ACTED
SOONER.
I ASKED THE PRESIDENT ABOUT THE
CRITICISMS MOMENTS AGO.
>> SHOULD YOU HAVE TAKEN THE
STEPS SOONER?
>> IF WE HAD BEEN BETTER MIND
READERS I GUESS WE COULD HAVE.
WE MOVED AND WE HAVE TO MOVE
WITH CAUTION AND SPEED TO MAKE
SURE WHAT WE GET IS IN FACT
FIRST RATE PRODUCT AND WHY THE
FDA HAS TO GO THROUGH THE
PROCESS.
>> Reporter: THAT'S A DEFENSIVE
REACTION FROM A PRESIDENT WHOSE
ADMINISTRATION IS TRYING TO SHOW
THEY ARE ON TOP OF THE ISSUE.
DID IT IS A DIFFERENT ANSWER
THAN I GOT FROM JEN PSAKI SAYING
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION IS ON
TOP OF THIS WORKING TO INCREASE
PRODUCTION FROM OTHER
MANUFACTURERS LIKE GERBER AND
RICKETTS BUT STILL A LOT MORE
WORK TO DO AS PARENTS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY ARE STRUGGLING TO FIND
FORMULA ON THE SHELVES.
>> INDEED.
JEREMY AT THE WHITE HOUSE, THANK
YOU.
RIGHT NOW LET'S DIG DEEPER WITH
ELIZABETH COHEN.
WHAT DO PARENTS NEED TO KNOW?
WHAT ARE THE DOs AND DON'Ts IN
THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE?
>> UNFORTUNATELY THERE ARE MORE
DON'Ts THAN DOs.
TAKE A LOOK.
FOR EXAMPLE, DO NOT MAKE YOUR
OWN FORMULA.
INFANT FORMULA IS BALANCED
CAREFULLY WITH THE VITAMINS AND
MIN KAWHI LEONARDS AND PROTEINS
AND SUGARS.
IT COULD HURT YOUR BABY AND
DON'T GIVE COW'S MILK OR
SOYMILK.
BREAST MILK OR INSTANT FORMULA
AND DO NOT WATER DOWN THE
FORMULA.
THE CHILD CAN GET VERY SICK IF
YOU DO.
THEY WON'T GET THE CALORIES THEY
NEED.
TALK TO THE PEDIATRICIAN.
YOUR PEDIATRICIAN DOESN'T KNOW
OF A SECRET STASH OR KNOW OF A
STORE YOU DON'T KNOW ABOUT BUT
IF THERE'S A MEDICAL PROBLEM
THEY COULD BE HELPFUL TO GETTING
IN TOUCH WITH FORMULA COMPANIES
OR INSURANCE COMPANIES TO GET
FORMULA AND IF YOU'RE A MOTHER
THAT STOPPED BREASTFEEDSING THEY
CAN PUT YOU IN TOUCH WITH A
CONSULTANT TO HELP YOU
RE-ESTABLISH DID BREASTMILK
SUPPLY.
>> ARE THERE OTHER RESOURCES TO
HELP PARENTS FIND BABY FORMULA?
>> THERE ARE RESOURCES THAT
PARENTS CAN CONSULT.
I'M NOT SURE IT HELPS YOU TRACK
DOWN FORMULA.
THE FIRST ONE IS THE WEBSITE
HHS.GOV/FORMULA.
THERE'S NUMBERS FOR THE FORMULA
COMPANIES.
FROM WHAT I COULD SEE AGAIN YOU
WON'T FIND A SECRET STASH BUT
GOOD INFORMATION OUT THERE THAT
MIGHT HELP ANSWER SOME OF YOUR
QUESTIONS.
PROBABLY NOT GOING TO LEAD YOU
DIRECTLY TO A STASH OF FORMULA.
ABBOTT WHICH MAKES SIMILAC.
THEY HAVE A FINDER WHERE YOU PUT
IN THE ZIP CODE AND THE BRAND
YOU LOOK FOR AND TELL YOU STORES
WHERE IT IS AVAILABLE BUT I'M
SORRY TO SAY THIS BUT MANY
PARENTS HAVE TOLD US THEY PUT IN
THE ZIP CODE A